okay for people uh
joining this live stream we are looking
at the
state of the world language compiler
preparing for version 13.1
so
let's take a look here
all right so there's a couple different
uh a couple different things here uh i'm
we're probably not going to get through
all of them but some of these like in
particular uh these two are probably not
for thirteen one so they're you know it
doesn't matter if we don't get to them
um
but right well i'd like to see them look
exciting okay yes
so okay so the first the first thing is
is some memory management things um so
basically this is
uh dealing with both types that are not
memory managed so you have to manually
free them you know allocate them etc and
then also you know how to
sort of encapsulate those types to make
the memory managed so that you don't
have to do those things and by memory
managed i basically mean reference
counted um
so the first the first thing which is a
bit different from from last time was
sort of trying to
uh you know consolidate all of the
unsafe operations together so basically
they're
the main unsafe operation that can
actually crash your kernel that that you
can do in the compiler that you can't do
in the top level is dereferencing um and
of course dereferencing also includes
indexing into c arrays because that's a
form of dereferencing
um
so sort of the
uh one proposal
was to
write to sort of
both to sort of scare people away from
using two pointer and from pointer uh to
basically uh
do unsafe stuff with pointers without
realizing it's unsafe
um the sort of idea was to well poison
the names somehow by maybe calling them
something like too unsafe from unsafe
pointer
and then the other idea was to sort of
there was the question of how to do uh
indexing into c arrays um and so
previously you know you you could just
use part but then that was i think a
little bit dangerous because part
doesn't look very unsafe but in fact
this operation could crash your kernel
if you index out of range so the idea
would also be to sort of put uh
indexing into these into these functions
because again indexing from cras is kind
of a form of uh let's understand what
does the code look like here so this is
if i say to unsafe point to open close
am i going to get some random hex
address there
well it won't do anything in the top
level we'll throw a message in the top
level um if you do this in compiled code
okay so so each one of these does
slightly different things so this one um
and mostly the first three we talked
about last time but but um that was a
while ago so so the first one basically
allocates on the stack
um and it will
sort of allocate with some you know it's
equivalent to saying you know int x
right so it won't actually populate it
with any initial value really um and it
will it'll infer
uh what the type is
um when you use the pointer
they don't have to wait wait if it's if
it's an array how can it have
how does it know what that what's a
piece of what's a code fragment that
uses okay so you might write something
like this you'd say let's let's pretend
i'm going to call some uh some library
some c function i've imported from you
know my library
function and and my library function you
know in proper c style what it's going
to do is it's going to take a pointer
and then it's going to you know populate
that pointer with the output if there is
any output and then it's going to return
an error code right this is a very
common idiom in c
so the way you would do that is you'd
say you know out equals to unsafe
pointer open close
then you you feed out to this and then
you'd say from unsafe pointer of out and
this would give you that that value and
if you were being
proper you would check the error code
before dereferencing it but
right so this is kind of equivalent to
uh
let me see
to basically the
this this idiom you write intex
my library function of
ampersand x
x
okay i understand
so right another way of thinking about
it is that you'd say you'd say in star
out equals ampersand x and then you'd
use out here and then when you want the
value you do something like that
right that seems more analogous to the
code you have yes
uh
okay so the
it'll be in star out equals x not
ampersand x sorry
uh well no because x is a pointer it's
ampersand x i think right yeah it is it
is it's the address of x
yeah
sorry yes
you would do
insta
out
um start out equals x so but yes that's
that's right
anyway fine right
right
okay
so
right so this is functionality we talked
about last time i think the only
difference here is that before it was
called two pointer and now
it's called two unsafe pointer
um what's somebody saying how do i get a
safe pointer
there is no such thing as a safe pointer
or i i should say this i
so okay we're going to talk below
there's a there's another thing which
needs a name but which is basically a
way of taking things like pointers and
other kinds of uh these sort of raw
objects and encapsulating them in a way
that makes them safer um that basically
gives them reference counts and so on
but the point is that these operations
are
are unsafe operations maybe maybe that's
the way to think about it it's not that
it's unsafe pointer maybe the unsafe
should go somewhere else because really
it's you know the operation is unsafe
not the pointer
um this operation is safe
although you you sort of have to be a
little bit careful because then if you
uh if you return this pointer from your
function it was allocated on the stack
so if you access it again you know if
you call from pointer this operation is
very unsafe because you don't know if
the pointer is
is is
i don't understand whether i mean this
stuff is all in compiler code only this
is not in top level
yes
so
the indication of unsafeness could be
given by coloring
in the you know in the syntax coloring
of the compiler code lexically it could
be indicated without having to name it
in some way that makes i mean in other
words when you type in the code
it can turn you know
i don't know
that's a bit dubious proposition stephen
people read these things out of wl files
and then they're not going to get you
know in their text editor they don't get
anything
yeah okay
um
i mean some syntax coloring for all this
is a good idea and we should we should
have a program for that
um but yes right
okay but
you want some indication i mean the main
thing is the dereferencing
thing
right well actually this operation
though this is this is the operation
that that's equivalent to like uh
you know setting the value setting an
element in a c array
that's also uh
that's also uh
why is it that way around why isn't it
pointer offset value
um
i guess it could be pointer offset value
i mean i i put it like this because uh
because you know the second usage is
pointer value
i know but i i think it i think it has
to be
i mean or
yeah it looks more low offset or
something
comma value
because you know that's more like
replace part yeah but it's not like a
part you see
so the offset
well yeah this is one of the questions
that that we need to get into but but
well okay one of the questions is
basically you can either think of this
as an offset or as an index if you think
of it as an index it's one index if you
think of it as an offset it's zero
indexed
so
that's a that's a separate question but
we should get to that in a second
um okay
but
i mean if if
if we use the technical name like
dereference
that might
encourage people that you've got to kind
of understand something to use this
well
for you
i mean that's the idea of unsafe is also
reinforcing there's some danger i i know
but but but it's not an unsafe pointer
it is merely the dereferencing operation
which is unsafe
well another option would be to say
something like from pointer unsafe
right like this is they're making more
clear the pointer isn't the thing that's
unsafe
but then people will be looking around
where's the safe version of this you
know where's the slower but safe version
of this and there isn't one
well no there isn't there isn't i mean
there's no way you can really check
if if you're indexing out of range or
something
i think this is a piece of babysitting
that i think is is a
you know
uh let's see
i mean i do think two raw pointer or
something might indicate that it's a
little bit more
kind of low level
i mean maybe pointer i mean this is the
other this is this is the exactly the
other fear which is i i fear the the for
loop problem right that you put a
function called four in the language and
then everyone who writes c says oh great
that's how i'll do all my loops i know
we're we're going to put something i
just decided that we need to have a
bright banner at the top of that page in
the documentation that just says this is
a mistake don't use it
right so let's not make another mistake
by i mean right this is one of the
reasons why i think
two pointer is a little bit scary
because there'll be so many people who
you see who say oh i want a pointer here
is there a way of doing that oh yes two
pointer
right and i want to scare people poison
yeah i agree that's a good argument
i mean really the only purpose of this
function is interacting with external
libraries that's the only time you
should really use it correct
okay my only problem with unsafe to
unsafe point right i get your argument
it's a good argument
um
it does make it sound like the pointer
is unsafe yeah no it also makes it sound
like there's a safe version that's
slower
right um
i like your idea of poisoning the name
i mean if we'd called for loop
you know
right
well that's another that's another thing
which is um you know
right now the type is called pointer i
think we can name these whatever we want
and keep the type called pointer but
another option would be to change the
name of the type as well um
but
yeah
i think they're kind of two independent
things
what do you think about the name raw
pointer
i think that that could be okay it would
be true raw pointer from raw pointer
yeah
and i think it's
yeah i think that suggests it's quite
low level and
you know
i mean
to pointer i take your point
um that i could well imagine people just
thinking oh that's the way to program
to raw pointer it feels a little bit
more kind of you know
uh
you know
i don't know what less less
less like it's the thing that the
high-level programmer should be doing
that would be my suggestion
okay yeah well i know i know also
there's some precedence i'm trying to
remember exactly what the distinctions
are if i remember right in swift for
example they have this they have unsafe
pointers and they have like unsafe raw
pointers
i don't know exactly what the difference
is but but yeah so i think raw pointers
is a fine fine name and it would be two
raw pointer from raw pointer i think so
okay okay but let's talk about those
values and offsets and things okay so
yes
what is that first argument when you say
ptr is that another is that an output
what does it return i mean what does
what does two raw pointer actually
return
okay so uh
well different
uh
right okay so different things depending
on the usage this returns a pointer
what does that mean an address
your computer yeah but i mean if i said
echo of that what would it do
it wouldn't work because there's no
expression serialization of pointers
well we might decide i mean it could it
would it might show a random number it
it could show a random number i think it
would be good for round number yeah
okay well there's all separation
i mean into an integer or you could do
you could cast it to an integer and
print that i mean you you could expose
extract the
the address the value yeah that would be
possible
okay
then
this one does basically the exact same
thing except it initializes the value
this one
sets the value into the pointer and then
i believe it returns the pointer not the
value right
because this one's trying to be like set
basically but then the other one the
initializer should also return i mean
two raw
points they all return
the pointer sort of okay i think they
should return the pointer yeah they
should always do that
right so now the question is given that
you so you're putting value last
i really think it should be point to
offset value
yeah i think that's i think that's fine
yeah now there's one question which is
does this return
so
i guess this should probably return the
pointer as well or
probably a c array which is basically a
pointer
um
which the only thing is it's a slightly
unfortunate because in these examples
you know you can think of this as being
like set
right like being you know set a pointer
come a vowel and then you know and then
it's you know set usually returns the
value but you could think set also might
just be returning the pointer and the
pointer evaluates to the value you get
what i mean yes
but but this one the analogy breaks down
a bit because we say you know pointer of
uh you know offset equals vowel and then
it returns pointer then you know it's uh
oops
and it's very different but i agree i
think it should return the pointer and
not the value
that would be so useful because you
could put it into the
into the function call
well let me also point out if if that
syntax was pointer arrow offset
the thing could return that kind of
object
some kind of object
that is some maybe that's crazy because
you can't use it in the compiler
so i'm saying if that was two raw
pointer of pointer arrow offset comma
val
yeah a decorated form of pointer
that correct yeah i'm a little i'm a
little skeptical of that yeah i think
it's probably a bad idea because because
that that structure itself is not
understandable to the compiler well it
it it would be actually because rules
rules are understandable so you know
well although i don't know if there's i
mean
this is the sort of thing where yes you
could probably do with rules but you
might actually do it with a macro
because i'm not sure if there's a you
know if you're doing this a billion
times because you're it's some low level
thing you're doing i'm not because
you're doing with feelings arrays i'd
rather optimize right optimization code
to optimize that to the thing that you
want
okay let me just point out this one
could be better than using a macro so
two raw pointer it's going has got to
return a pointer so i think this thing
about thinking it is a set
yeah yeah it's not a set
right fine so it's true off pointer and
then there's the question of um
i'll just write it here then there's the
question of of whether the offset is an
offset or an index you don't mean raw
that looks like an
[Music]
[Laughter]
oldie um
okay
is that offset is it is a zero
boy that's a i mean if it's called
offset i think it's going to be zero
origin
sorry if it's an offset i think it
should come last
so it's definitely not like replace part
i see
i'm calling an offset here but it could
be you can just as easily call it the
index yeah that's just the documentation
well but the index then will be one
origin
yes
that this is the question
oh boy
well i mean what is this going to be
used for so it's used for interacting
with libraries
and what side of that interaction is
this dealing with in other words is it
mostly going to be indexing interval
from language arrays or into c arrays
series well yeah i mean this only
indexes into serial numbers
it's part of nothing for anything that
we have yeah
but
this creates
this takes a pointer
i mean like for example if we were
writing
this is going to get super confused
right let's say you write a table
let's let's say you write do
okay
yeah do
to raw pointer if you just write it do
two raw pointer
of pointer
comma
yeah okay
yes equals i squared or something
yeah
so
so so let me show you actually a very
common example that you'd also write
which i've written you know several
times which is stuff like um
uh like this
right so i have some i have some
realistically this code will be you know
we'll have casts for this you won't have
to write it yourself but this is
basically oh it's going to be one
version it's just got to be one origin
otherwise it's just going to be
unbelievably irreducibly confusing right
we have to do stuff like this no no no
it's that's horrifying
all right fine then then it's one origin
and it's index i think
yeah
all right and then this is also an
origin um
let's just walk through that function
from real pointer for a second
yeah so that is essentially a
uh that first thing is equivalent to
frontal point of ptr comma one
and
yeah
uh
i mean i just find it so confusing
because i'm thinking about
you know am i going to get a thing with
lists around it or not and that ptr
thing
you know normally in our language
the unparted thing
has a list back around it but obviously
in a non-symbolic world that's not what
happens
you don't know whether to think of this
as a as an array or a list or it's just
a singular object
right right i'm thinking of that you
know obviously in c
you know there's no such thing i mean
yeah
eraser pointers which are singular
objects
yes
i think it's necessary i mean this seems
like a good theory it's i think it'd be
desirable to see some code but i do
think that the one origin thing is un
unavoidable if it's going to interact
with other functions
right fine
um
right and i think uh again realistically
this is this is really only going to be
used for interacting with library code
so
yeah but but what is a little bit
confusing to me about that is
when you say interacting with library
code i'm a little worried that
somebody's going to read off in a c
debugger
you know these elements of the array oh
whoops they're off by one
right well that actually that that's
maybe one other issue which is suppose
you might also do something like like
this
you know
and i have my uh
my you know
right where this library function is
sort of uh
uh
assuming that it's uh
that that it's zero indexed or something
well i mean
so the other possibility which is
probably too crazy
is to imagine different functions for
zero index and one index
i think i i remember some you know this
this is where then there's the proposal
for the compromise of having it just be
1.5 indexed or 0.5
but we could say two raw point is zero
two row point of one
but you mean have a two raw point is
zero draw point two one yep
that's that's very you know that's like
those weasels
hyper geometric f zero functions or
whatever
what is this
that
andrew is saying
isn't that what solomon proposed yeah i
think that's the 1.5 oh yes right oh is
it okay yeah
um
so i mean obviously
in the case where you're not offsetting
there's no zero one issue
in the one argument case there's no
issue right actually even in the two
argument cases
correct that's that's that's correct
yeah it's because in this case you're
going to be passing it a pointer or or
you're going to be passing a cra
thing with type c array
um
[Music]
okay
i think this is complicated and i'm not
sure i i think
i mean the problem is it's going to be
interacting both with library functions
and with
the other compiler functions that are
one indexed
god
well on the library function thing so so
okay here's a question
is there a possibility of a harness that
can change from zero index to one index
yeah you can shift the address well i
know by one right but i mean is there
something where in in as a headdress to
that library function thing that there
could be a
uh
you know if you just write out the [ __ ]
the thing just write out a function no
no just on a separate line just the
function one index
o n e index
no no no o any index
another function zero index
you know zero index
and my question would be is there any
conceivable way to make those into
headdresses
no
because this function i mean
who like
i think there's there's no way of
knowing you know this function could be
yeah there's no way i mean this function
could just be a function returning an
integer
right just taking an integer and
returning an integer and you have no
idea is that integer just a random
integer is that an index into some array
that you're giving me is that
you know who knows
and if you need to and if you know what
it is and how it's indexed
between them it's a matter of plus one
minus one which i i can't imagine you
could put the one index around the i
i mean you you you could do that
or the zero index around the eye i mean
you could do that
okay what about using the type system is
there any possibility of using the type
system to indicate that something is a
zero origin index
i mean to an extent if we just say that
c arrays are zero indexed and that you
index into them with this
function
then
then they're zero indexed and that's a
way of doing it with the type system
there's zero index but then the element
one of the zero index thing
is the otherwise to see 0
index object is that correct
like i mean not without having an
integer that's a zero origin integer or
you know it it's a bit no not not not
but
if i've got a c array
and i say
uh
two raw pointer
of or no i say from raw pointer of the c
array comma one
right okay is that going to give me the
element of the c array let's say the c
array is you know is that the first or
the second argument well let's imagine
that the c declaration is in x ten x of
10 okay
is it x of zero
does that give me x of zero
that's exactly the question here whether
it's an offset or an index you know i
know i know i know i know but what we're
proposing right now
is that that cra comma one gives me
the x sub zero element
that's what we're discussing that's the
index option
but that's what you're proposing there
well i don't know i'm i'm
i honestly i was
more partial to the offset option
but um i i don't have a super strong
opinion because i think both of them are
going to have awkward situations and
yeah
well but in the offset option are you
suggesting that the offset
argument comes last
i i think it could come in the middle
too i i honestly don't think it i think
coming in the middle is fine because it
looks more like it looks more like you
know
okay
like this
i think we should go on and look at
other things i think this is a as they
say in the the old country a sticky
wicket
sure right okay well i think we do we
need to resolve that whether it's zero
or one index though i mean otherwise it
seems like these other things are kind
of um
you know fine but yeah i mean it's going
to be zero index in the seaside i mean
that's
we're sure about that i presume
how can it not be no that's crazy to not
do that isn't that true well yes i mean
that's just saying so right no well i
mean
you just have to do some conversion or a
shift or something
so how would you do that i mean and
you can always just make an array that's
one element longer than than it needs to
be and then just ignore the first
element of it but but this is not
something we're going to do
what fraction are there any
kind of low level you don't have to make
it bigger you you could just shift the
address
so it was either to the left or the
right depending what you want
i'm losing track of these things but
were there any um
you know like fortran has won the next
arrays i think maybe they changed it
but
all the c derivative languages are all
zero and x arrays
is that true pretty much yeah i mean i'm
trying to think of what what what
languages could produce
libraries that would be one index i mean
the only might be julia i'm not even
sure julia can produce libraries though
probably can does it have one index or
right
it does it's true yeah yeah
it does but they're just also for
reference their uh c interface like
their foreign function interface to c
um
they use zero indexed arrays i believe
um but their interface is also kind of
weird so that might be uh
taking the grain of salt
yeah various people on our livestream
are suggesting
uh options about
for raw pointer i think
i think we should feel like if you're if
you if you know enough about what's
going on to use an option you can just
as easily say minus one or plus one okay
my only my only argument against that is
readability of code
that if you've got a bunch of plus ones
and minus ones raw in the code
it's very obscure what's going on i mean
that could be there because you know for
all kinds of different weird reasons
correct but but i mean this is the i
mean i think the problem the biggest
danger here is the fact that people will
assume that it's one or the other and
they'll be wrong or they'll be copying
code from either the sort of well from
language side or the sea side and
they'll be sort of transcribing it and
they'll assume the wrong thing
right so
yeah i think the issue is going to be
more about people not knowing what it's
going to do as opposed to people knowing
what it's going to do and having to go
through the pain of changing the
indexing
well but you see my argument about you
know raw pointer one rule point to zero
would deal with that
it provides notice that this is a thing
that is a raw point what about
the first three usages or would be
identical for these two
functions so i mean really it shouldn't
even be too raw point it should be some
other function
zero and one
well maybe that's the mistake maybe the
offset function is wrong
maybe that's setting the offset thing is
wrong
i i just think it's very weird to have
two functions you know
whose only difference is basically
whether or not the you know takes the
argument and subtracts one for it from
it
hold on let's just think about this
possibility that there's a different
function that deals with the offset case
yeah
to raw offset pointer
okay so let's try this two raw offset
pointer
well it would be pointer offset to raw
pointer offset it would be offset
okay
to raw offset raw pointer or something
or two raw pointer off i mean the wrong
oh it's not to a point to offset it's
it's two raw offset it's an offset of
the pointer isn't it no but the pointer
raw pointer is the wrong pointer type
right that's what the pointer type is
yeah i see
well okay so then two raw pointer offset
zero two row off pointer offset one
do we have any other um
i mean
this is an obscure case i mean this is
going to be
uh
[Laughter]
it wins on it wins on literacy
it does and i think it will reduce bugs
i mean if we had that then every single
time somebody uses it they're gonna
think
is this am i gonna do zero offset you
know zero index
you know which one should i use
like if i'm just writing some piece of
code that's interfacing some library i
don't know how i pick between them
well because all i'm doing is i'm just
you know i'm creating this array and i
just need to for for example right it's
a common thing that you'll you'll you'll
feed in some big big array and then
separately you'll feed an argument
that's be some you know length
three array where you specify what the
dimensions of the big array are right
like if you if you if it's a it's a
flattened form of a you know some higher
order tensor
right so if i'm doing that all i'm doing
is i'm creating a c array and then i'm
populating three arguments and three
three values into it and then i'm
passing it in which of these should i
use
something where you don't have plus raw
plus ones and minus ones no but either
way i'm just going to be basically
writing you know
pointer comma you know
four comma one pointer comma five comma
two right i'm just i just need to
populate three arguments into the thing
let's say
i mean realistically you probably use
casting for this but but you know let's
say i'm doing that right should i use
the zero or one indexed one
my point is just i think there will be
lots of situations where you really can
use either one and it will be equally
kind of clean
and so i think you know having just two
basically identical functions would make
it just sort of mysterious
okay then i'm going to still make the
argument two raw pointer offset
is better than putting that combining
that with two raw pointer with a third
argument
because at least serves notice that
there's an offset involved
so you might think you know the word
offset is not so often used in our
system
if we want zero indexed
or it makes you think in general
this makes you think i mean
we better move on to some other topics
but that would be my i mean look
i don't know christopher what do you
think i mean in this role point to
offset do you think that's crazy and
over over
i think it's a little bit i mean i think
that you know if we're not using this
for anything else it's a little bit
weird because again this is really a
very very similar operation if this were
its own function i'd also think a bit
about the name because
i mean we could support this for for
pointers you know but but but really
you're mostly going to be doing on
things with type c array not things with
type raw pointer um
so
we should have an offset with pointers i
think just the offset would be not
defined for
okay so it only works on c array so it
would be weird if it has raw pointer in
its own
this is a nasty this is a look this is
interfacing to the jungle basically and
it's hard sure right
the final option just just to mention it
because this is how i think it works
right now is just with part so you'd
have your cra you say part zero and it's
zero indexed oh god you know but but
this i think is no that's not truly
crazy in my view yes
and it hides the fact that it's very
unsafe so
so i think it should be two row pointer
pointer comma offset comma value and i
guess it should be zero indexed
all right yeah i think that's i think
that's reasonable i mean i think that's
yeah i don't i don't fully understand
the context but let's let's go let's try
to go with that
fine um is there anything we can do to
be defensive
in terms of this design i mean i guess
the defensive way to back out of this
design is to go to two separate
functions
to deprecate
yeah the
yeah it's not to use a good name is to
be defensive
i know but
but i mean i think the thing is there's
really no other i i can't think of any
other use of a three argument form of
true raw pointer anyway fine okay so
then the defensive back out would be we
deprecate the three argument form of two
raw pointer and use another name for the
setting thing
yeah i think that that sounds good
okay all right let's move on all right
so the next uh
okay so the next thing is basically
uh
right this is uh
this is sort of a very small point i
mean this one which probably kind of
skip but basically um
the point is is that there's sort of an
issue which is when you when you create
you know an instance of a of a type
right so when you declare you know say a
type product you can you can request
there's an option for type declaration
which you basically say uh memory
managed arrow true false automatic
whatever and if you say true that means
it's reference counted and if you say
false it means it's not
so if it's not reference counted that
means know you have to manage it
yourself you'll have to call delete
object on it you know when you're done
with it and otherwise it'll leak
so the kind of the issue is
in the idea of trying to indicate to
people when they're doing something you
know they should be careful with is just
that there's no indication when you call
create type instance
whether you're creating something that
you're going to need to free yourself or
something that is going to be memory
managed um yes and so it's sort of you
know that could lead to to leaks um and
you know especially in cases where it's
you know this will happen with types
that users define but it'll also happen
with some types that we define so like c
array that's an unmanaged thing so you
better know that if you if you write
this line here you better know to free
it later but there's no real indication
of that in this line
um
so
other than the name of the type
right other than if you you know that c
arrays are not memory managed right now
i think there are very few things that
won't be memory managed like i mean
cras are probably i mean c-rays are i
think the only one we would we would
document right now i can't think of
really any others that we'd immediately
want maybe we should have a prefix raw
raw cray
to indicate that it's not memory managed
does that cause the use of raw and raw
pointer
um
not quite because it's not raw c pointer
i would argue i mean i would argue the c
prefix is already kind of the i mean the
reason we have the c prefix yeah
like to tell you
so so there is a way you know we'll see
in the next section there is actually a
way of creating a cra that's sort of in
a wrapper
that that makes it memory managed um
okay it'll still be up to that okay fine
this is nice this is this is all quite
nice so the semantics of this i think
are pretty good but there's some naming
there's some naming things so basically
the idea is there's this there's this
type that needs a name but it's right
now just called managed and basically
what manage does is uh
it uh it's sort of like a a wrapper you
put around your your other objects and
that basically has a reference count and
when it's reference count goes to zero
it'll free the object that it's holding
i thought we were not doing this
stringer's head
thing
oh well yes this thing i've got we've
got a syntax for that i i've implemented
it
well did you okay well there's the
syntax
yeah that's that's the syntax i've
implemented that is it in all the causes
no it's in the colonel parser i i just
did that this afternoon but i think it
works
do we like that
i think it's quite nice i think i think
it's i mean shall i go and tell people
should i make a pr should i tell
other people to why don't you see how
much they complain if you start putting
that out there john thoughts never
complains
i'll start with i'll start with john um
but we've got multiple
parts
yes yes but i think john's the key one i
don't know the front end i think if the
front end does it the other ones can
follow
okay
right so so either way though um
you know but basically you can so so the
the the most basic usage is this which
is i have my unmanaged thing and then i
create an instance of the managed thing
and i give it my unmanaged thing
um and then optionally there's it takes
it over right right there's an optional
third argument which is basically the
the freeing function function to call
when you want to free this thing um
because sometimes you can't tell just
from the type
um
create type instance generically has a
freeing function
no
create type instance just you know
basically takes the type in the first
argument and it takes
arguments
in the rest of its arguments and now it
allocates memory so it always allocates
memory and it fills out with the
arguments so it looks for a creating
function
that has to exist so
sorry
is the freeing function an option or is
the freeing function a third argument
it's an optional personal argument you
can just
it's not that's honestly not an
important point for this right here okay
you won't need it almost all the time
correct um
so it's all right so this is how you
take if you had a cra this is how you
wrap it up in a way that so it'll call
free on it when it's done
alternatively you can also just you know
go straight for it and just you know say
create type instance give me a man
c array
and then that will just do these steps
together
um and basically what this would do is
it'll give you a thing with type managed
of c array
you know which is which is reference
counted and which you know if the
reference count goes to zero it'll free
the array so it just makes it safer um
and why is it that we don't just have a
um
uh
managed c array as a type
because you want a c array to pass into
c code that has to be
the raw stuff you see
so that's
so
right so this is exactly the um
this next section so basically ignore
these first points so so when you have
if you have a c function that you've
loaded using library function
declaration and let's say the c function
is declared to take a c array
if you just pass it this managed object
it will automatically you know unwrap it
and and you know pass the see your
agency function
um
so
yeah
that's kind of the point
um
so i mean should it be called memory
managed or managed or what what is this
that's there are two questions that's
the first question what should be called
memory managed um
i think there are some issues with it
being called memory managed like the
fact that well
uh for example the option for to type
declaration is also called memory
managed which makes it a little bit
strange that there's a type called
memory managed and this option
there's also what i can do
it makes it it makes the type memory
managed or not now is it create type
instance cra blah blah memory managed
arrow true or something yeah type
declaration type declaration
my type
stuff you know memory managed goes to
false
can i see how that should look like so
there's a
right there's um app decoration got
string options there
you mean this should be a symbol yes it
probably should be a symbol
except i i'm worrying about that
uh
memory managed is something i could
imagine wanting to use as a rapper of
some kind
as we just saw
well
and and also
well yeah there's also a minor technical
thing so there's also an abstract type
so
whether these things abstract types
which you can you know are sort of high
order you know
ways of keeping types together right yes
ways of grouping types they're type
classes
um you know so you can have like a type
class for like things that are like
lists that you can index into for
example
you know
so there's a type class called memory
managed that's basically the type class
of all things that are memory managed um
so
i mean we can change the name of that of
course but like the you know
in the convention for how you name type
classes if there is such type class
memory managed is kind of the right name
for it
yes
but then so wait a minute so this option
memory managed to false just seems
really weird
well i mean do you think it should just
have a different name
yes
i mean
okay this is a type declaration
uh i mean you're also called snake
reference counted or something
well or we could make a more general
name and say
this is
a
you know this is some feature of a
declared type
and one of its features is you know it's
a list of features and one of them is
managed for example well you know okay
this is the old syntax for it pretty
much which is you can say
abstract types just another string
option and then you give it a list of
all the abstract types that this is a
member of and and
if you do this
you basically say i'm a member of the
the the class of of you know why do you
need to give that as an option why is
that fourth argument an option
why isn't it just a fourth argument
the abstract types that you remember
there might be other there might be
other settings to do with the type as
well i mean there are other other things
you can give
yeah like there's several different
you know
yeah there's several if you want to make
this a fourth argument there are
probably some other things that could
also try and be a fourth argument
i think you need optional argument named
optionally named all right okay but but
abstract types is really obscure i mean
is there another possible
uh sort of catch-all option name
well in general i think that should be
called abstract types because we have
abstract type declarations
so you can do stuff like like like this
oh boy
so this would be something like you know
uh
suppose i mean this is one way you could
do it suppose i had types for directed
graphs and undirected graphs and i
wanted functions that take all of them
i'd have an abstract type of graphs
and then
you know i'd have functions that take
anything that's in graphs
right
okay all right look
i i think that it is the least
horrifying that the string memory
managed to error false is probably the
least horrifying for right now
yes and then that was the theory but
many
sort of compatibility things that can be
done later if it turns out that isn't
quite right
right right so then the question remains
what this should be called
um what's wrong with managed i think
managed is nice i i i like management
okay maybe they managed to find me i i
sort of put managers like a placeholder
it was previously called unmanaged
because the idea is that it would wrap
unmanaged things but that was too
confusing no no no i think it it makes a
managed thing i i think i think this is
yes
fine then then it can be managed well
okay so then the next question with it
is um
okay so
most of the time probably the way you're
going to use these is you're going to
pass them to c functions and they'll be
automatically unwrapped and everything
will be great but if for some reason you
need to unwrap them the question is how
to do that so the semantics of it are i
think fairly fixed the way the semantics
has to work is that you'll have some
function
and you know unwrap and and you'll call
unwrap on your managed object and it
will basically invalidate the managed
object and then give you out the thing
that it was wrapping because what you
don't want to happen is that it unwraps
it it gives you the inner object but
then that managed object when its
reference count goes to zero it's going
to free its inner object but you still
have that object you don't want that to
happen so so it has to invalidate it so
the question is what should that thing
be called one option is normal no no not
normal is terrible
well okay the argument for normal is
that it's basically you know it's taking
some wrapped cra or whatever you want
and it's
right the problem is side effects yeah
you see you wouldn't be able to call
normal twice the second time would be a
runtime runtime error why isn't the
thing a cast of some kind i mean
a cast that mutates the thing that you
give it
yeah that's weird as well i mean it's
like a transfer or a move or something
or in c plus plus and in you know it's
called move
right
sir it could be type move or something
it could be something like that
or type instance move
i mean i i think that the problem with
uh something like type instance move is
just that it's like that's so obscure
everything we have is called type you
know everything involves type instances
so it's like a compiler it's a typed
system but yes
um
that's that's better than normal um
i think that's better than move
so you think what convert would be
better than move
it's not converting yeah it's not
converting
yeah
type instance convert was one of the
other names that you proposed last time
for cast so i think
yeah
okay but but
can you
distinguish this from a cost other than
its side effect
uh
not really i mean i think it's it's
casting i think more it's like going
horizontally i mean this is more going
vertically and since it's just
unwrapping the thing correct it's just
giving you a field of a struct and also
invalidating the struct
um
well if it's for this specific case
maybe it should be called type unmanage
i mean it's utterly obscure but that's
less if you type it in type type i mean
this is a pretty utterly obscure
thing to do
that's that's not a bad name actually
because that is what it's doing
it's in i mean that
that's that's not bad should it be
unmanaged type or type unmanaged
well
i i i think these are both okay i mean
my
uh it should be type unmanaged because
unmanaged type sounds like literal type
of for all type which are types um
but
my only complaint would just be that i
think the type i mean
there's there's nothing really type-y
about this it's just everything in the
compiler involves types
um
well okay so what language is it what
about instance unmanaged what about raw
pointer on marriage
isn't it a rule pointer isn't it a
creature of raw pointers
yeah you could have anything in there
that's good unman unwrap managed i find
that very obscure
i think unmanaged is better because it
does suggest the possibility of a side
effect
just unmanage or type on manage
or something unmanaged
well i don't know what the something is
it'd be good to give
an unmanaged there i mean
it's too generic yeah yeah it's true
it's unmanaged we've used instant
somewhere else
but what is the thing that is unmanaging
so so we have a
right so we have
an object we have like a raw object like
we have an unmanaged object like this c
array and then we manage it
so no
it's unmanaging the cra i guess which is
currently man
right now we have a generic function
delete object
maybe we should have a generic function
unmanage object
or what does it i mean does it only
manage but right now it only does this
what else would it ever do
what well i could never do
i could imagine something where some
external
you know
deployment publishing mechanism
has
caused something within our system
to be
yeah go ahead if you want a more general
name
that that might actually it would be
something like
like
you know own or like transfer ownership
that would be the the more general
operations
i i don't think it should be that i
think it should be a name that sounds
utterly obscure like unmarriage
fine right i'm saying
i think this is actually a fine name but
i don't think it's worth thinking about
this is something like delete object
where it's going to be overloaded
correct correct
all right so it sounds like this is sort
of the
this is the winner i think so
so long as we don't object to object so
to speak
no i think object is fine no i think
object is good we've used should we have
create type object
no
all right fine okay okay fine yeah and
we do and we also use delete object for
for when you you know for for like craze
for example i mean delete object is free
okay so yeah so this is good all right
fine okay great this is good right can
we look at down value compilation yes
sure
so here basically i just decided i'll be
right back but
some well
so chris
christopher
yeah
so i've i've been running tests on your
create type instance branch and
something seems to be running really
slowly but i don't know what it might be
something on my machine but i'm
i want to get to the bottom of that so
um i can take a look i mean i ran the
tests there's nothing
it shouldn't be doing anything like that
oh and did you see my email about owned
i think owns a bad idea i think we
should just use the
callback thing so
yeah i i have a branch i could do that
if you want i think we need to get this
move you know wrap things up yeah for
sure you want me to do it well i'll
email you after me because i have a
branch that i think basically well send
me your branch and i i i could take a
look so but but i'm quite happy to do it
so and i did some stuff figuring things
out
right all right down value compilation
right so so this is basically i think
the implementation is basically there
it's a question of the top level design
um so so basically what this okay these
are just a few alternative designs but
basically the the
thing you're doing
is
i'm you you're basically
creating a uh
you're declaring a function
and instead of
and the way you're specifying it the
behavior of the function is instead of
providing a pure function you're just
giving it a symbol name and telling it
find the down values from the symbol and
use that instead
right
separately there's the issue of down
code compilation or compiling to down
code that's a different
that's a different situation
what do you mean by that
okay so so the point is this is just
taking the definition from down from
down values separately there's the issue
of of if i want to then call fib in the
top level and have it use compiled code
then i'd have to sort of compile to down
code so these are two things that you
want to use together a lot of the time
and and you know the designs of these
things i think but they're slightly
the end result is if you've got five
minutes defined at top level
you want to be able to say compile this
and you want to insert a new down code
definition
that goes in front of the down values
in its that's that's what down code
compilation is right
that's if you did both of them together
that's if you did both together which
would be the most common case
yes
yes hey hang on hang on
this down values thing it will transform
the workflows that people have for
working with the compiler it will really
improve them i know they'll end up with
a compiled code function but it'll make
working with a compiler
so what is the final thing that involves
both down value compilation and down
code insertion
right so so basically there'll be a
syntax
so this stuff is more tentative because
this stuff is not going to be ready for
13.1 and there's some questions about
how you
detect down codes because you know
because because you can't just call down
values and so on but it needs real
kernel changes to make this
you know
useful so right but it's basically
something like this function compile
export values or something like that
this is this is sort of a tentative name
and and basically what it'll do is is
you tell it about the functions that it
knows about from the type environment
and it will put them to down code so the
way you do this with with together with
down value compilation
is you you get your declaration like
this which basically just gives the type
and the symbol name and you would just
put it in like that and that would that
would do it yeah um
okay but look there clearly has to be a
function
if i've got my fib thing that's all
defined and so on it's clearly going to
be a thing that says
uh
you know
i don't know what it should be called i
mean compile just compile it well the
issue right now is just that at least
for now you have to specify the types
and and you can't do that currently
inside the down values so you have to do
it when you compile
i see so so we're basically saying
but the overall wrapper function would
be something like
uh you know if i mean it would be called
compile function if we didn't already
have that
um
well actually we don't have that we have
we have function compile
really we really can't have compiled
function in function compiler you could
have symbol compile
i don't think that's great either
values compile or something compile
values
but but but really i think these are
these are two slightly separate issues i
mean they're worse i know but i really i
want to understand the end point for a
second because i think it's important
that because that's going to be the 99
case
are people saying basically
let's call it i mean
uh
let's say it was called compile
definition
okay as a for the sake of having
something to say
okay and then say fib
comma
and then a type signature
that that that's that's fine yeah
i mean you could even actually do
something another way you could do it is
given that we have typed as you could do
this
i see
which is very similar to some of the
stuff down here but yeah that's
perfectly nice i mean either of those
seems perfectly nice
now down on our live streams asking why
not compile down values
i think we want to compile are we going
to be in a position to compile sub
values as well
uh potentially again i mean the problem
is is that
right right i mean the way that the dow
valley compilation works to my
understanding is i mean it basically
looks the down values and then it
creates these sort of uh you know it's a
driver function and it compiles that
right and so that driver function could
be a bit smarter and it could also work
for some values of things too
but
it doesn't right now
there's an argument though that you're
going to want to give multiple type
declarations
and you're going to need to say with
that type declarations for the sub value
of the down value so there's an argument
the function should actually be called
compile down values
i would why don't you type that in
another thing
sorry we're getting terribly confused we
need a way to add
the definition to the type environment
and
separately we need to have a way to
compile
from the type environment to down code
they're not the same thing we're
confusing them i i know they're not the
same thing right they're they're two
things you often want to do them
together but but but there are many
cases like especially down code
compilation there are tons of actually
yeah both of these you want to do them
independently a ton of the time correct
right without doing the other all right
but but could you just write at least
compile down values as possible
but now now i'm just going to just throw
out one one potential problem with this
which is that this is one of the
unresolved issues with down code
compilation is where does it go so to
speak in the sense that for other value
like for example if you call clear on
the symbol does it clear the down code
right now it doesn't down code i don't
think gets cleared when you clear a
symbol no another another thing is is uh
how do you is there any way of detecting
if the down code exists can you call you
know down values on on the symbol and i
think i think i think what you get is
in the down values list it is a
decorated first element of the down
values list yeah so we talked about that
and that's that's possible but that that
this requires
serious non-trivial kernel work that
will have consequences for all the
functions that look at down values i
know
yes
another another
this would be another option is to have
a different type of you know we have own
values sub values down values and we'd
also have sort of compiled values i see
and then the semantics would say that
those get used first
yeah
that's kind of interesting too
that's interesting and might be the best
solution because you could then clear
those
wait we don't really want to have to
re-configure the symbol structs for for
for this i mean that that doesn't matter
i don't think that i don't think it'll
be a bad thing i mean this is why i'm
also not sure that you need to i mean
like we could i don't think you need to
right
yeah i mean i i mean we could just have
it that there's down code and then and
then this thing kind of
effectively just tells you that there's
down cut whether whether there's down
code or not right that's fine but
i like that idea because i like the idea
of something went wrong with the
compiled code just being able to blow it
away
compile values of f equals dot
no
well that's that's that's that's true
i mean i think that's quite useful
particularly
you know in the it would be feasible to
have so when i started implementing the
kernel i added a flag to the symbol that
said it had compiled values
so you could have
something like store it in the down
values and you have this flag in the
symbol but it ignores the down value
uh
in the evaluator yeah okay you're
talking deep implementation
that's that's important
i know i know but
okay let's go back to what you actually
want to talk about for now yes
okay so basically this is the the the
case of
i have i have fib defined i want to get
bib into my compiler environment
right so i can use it right right so
basically this is sort of a pure syntax
question right all that you need to know
is you need to know the symbol the name
of the thing and you know it's type
um and you need to know
yeah that's the two pieces of
information okay how do you do this with
a pure function if fib was a pure
function what would you do okay you
would write you'd write this
no
and then you know add the if statement
to make it correct but yeah
i don't understand i mean i'm sorry
this is a declaration of that function
right this is a function declaration
okay so it declares and adds it to the
compiler environment and now in the
compiler if i call fib it will run this
so the typed is a headdress is a
that function's a sub really is that
right i thought type
typed has two two usages it has a
headdress form like this like an
operator form this is what this is an
operator form and it has a non-operator
form where this goes at the end
right
value version christopher
can you show what it looks like the
other yeah i just need to this is a more
basic issue hold on um
yeah yeah that's correct
okay fine
all right now write the down value
version
right so there's there's different
proposals for the down value version the
current implementation but i think it's
kind of weird works like this
right write the down values crystal
first do fib
yeah yeah
x
i can just
no no no but put the put the condition
in the down value you see
okay fine fine
yeah
right you see this is quite nice
actually i think
well this is what we've had for the last
35 years no no no but we can compile
this
this is actually implemented and
actually you'd have to put the
pattern test the condition inside the
fib but right
inside the argument that should be that
bug should be fixed yeah yeah fine
there's there's okay but so what's your
point here what's your point you'll find
just how to indicate
that you're going to pick up the value
exactly the function declaration exactly
right
so why isn't it just
that typed thing with automatic there
so there's separately there's there's a
thing okay so there's already something
similar which is right here i'm giving a
function of type i can also just write
type specifier here
right like i instead of giving the whole
typed object i can give just a tight
and this declares
a type of function called an erasure in
in the compiler which is basically just
a pure
type mapping function that that doesn't
have an implementation
right so so
this is used for sort of fairly
you know
fairly
low level
fancy type stuff
but so
you're doing that which might not be and
then
but the issue is
what if the thing actually has
um
you know
i'm a little confused why aren't you
just saying
function declaration of fib comma and
then the type signature
is that ambiguous with anything else
that's that yes
that's the erasure case
right
but that's a type
o
but why are you making that case be the
case that is easy to write
because the case it seems to me
is the one where you would use it
because i think there's a better there's
actually a slightly better one
okay so there's there's things like i
mean i think i think it's i think it's a
little weird to use this also for for
the down values because i think
i think it's useful to say somewhere you
know
please get the
the definition from and then somewhere
right as well as just not giving a
definition but that last one is good
look at that last one the down values
are fib no it isn't dumbbells if is a
list it's not a function
yeah i personally prefer this one but
it's making a single right right but you
haven't said down values
it is making a single function
that there really is a single function
for fib it encompasses all of the down
values
it is it is declaring a function called
fib
right
my complaint about this one is more of
the fact that overloaded function it's
it's a declaration it really is and you
could prune the down values you could
put other rules in there you could
reorder them you could do
whatever
okay hold on down values of fibers are
non-starter down values of fib returns a
list
why not allow having a list
of of you know rules
in in function declarations well okay so
that's okay so that so that's why why
not
yeah okay so that that's the actual
suggestion
convenient way to make it right my my
only complaint about that is the fact
that
that when you say typed normally you're
saying here's an object and here's the
type of that object but the type of this
object is not going to be this the type
of object is going to be some list of
rules that that's my only sort of
complaint
um
you're giving the implementation and it
is encompassing all of these rules but
fine
whatever right well then you what you
would have to do
is in that typed thing you would have to
have an outer wrapper to the type
that says it's a you know a rule list or
something if you said
some wrapper for um
so what i'm saying is in inside the
typed
it's like the ruleless dispatch or
something technically isn't it no it's
not quite dispatch
it's no i'm what i'm saying is inside
the typed if you put in there
um
uh
rule list colon colon open bracket and
then that thing
that's totally freaking weird
[Music]
because it's also not rule list isn't a
type or like you know yeah no no no not
a useful type that's no that's terrible
right sorry
okay because in the end fib is going to
be a function with that type that takes
integer to integer
you know that not not that right you
could put the rule list around the down
values
you could have a decorator around the
download no i'm thinking if you were
going to do that you could have a down
values function
that is
a form of down value is packaged as a
function
fine fine
that's also known as replace
but that's too weird
that's too weird
how you're ripping this is
know hang on replace isn't a function
replaces an expression
it has an operator form it has an
operator
so if i define this
you're correct
this is why i think i i kind of like
this one it doesn't say it's a down down
values anywhere but but you know it
it tells you
i'm compiling fib this is its type
and here's the definition i'm compiling
here's a symbol go find its values and
and one day maybe this will also look
for sub values of values own values
whatever you want
i mean
but you would also have the other form
where it's just typed of fib commerce
type signature yeah
you're not you're just giving the
operator form just for fun it's not it
will be equivalent to typed
and then and then not giving a
definition i i don't well the problem is
that you mean this this usage here
the problem is this usage means no no no
no no i didn't mean that definitely i
mean i mean
did you copy okay so instead of type to
blah at sign fib just put the fib inside
the type fine yes i can do it as not an
operator form yes there's no problem
with that working right yeah no no it's
no problem no there's no i mean they
would both work but uh okay so let me
just understand this it's weird to have
fiber appearing twice
but maybe not
maybe not
well it wouldn't be weird if they had
give it a different name i guess you
could have said one and get the
implementation from fib that actually
that might be useful it might be useful
yeah
okay so
let me just understand this semantically
that typed would usually contain a pure
function correct in place of the second
verb it would normally be a pure
function
yes that's applied to arguments
according to that type signature so this
seems correct
yeah
fine that's why i prefer this one yeah i
mean the one final option which i think
we had earlier on but i think was there
was some problem with it i'll mention it
anyway was just writing this
hang on write writing what
you're basically
one argument with one argument i think
the issue is that it was thought that
this is too weird because normally you
kind of have to give it the function
name it's too weird
i don't know why it's so weird
maybe there's also the issue that um
no right here here's also maybe an issue
so there is a one argument form of
function declaration which you can use
in the second argument of function
compile which is basically where you're
you're giving it the main function so it
doesn't have a name but you still might
want to give it options
um function generator is the way to add
options
but
this is going in anything anyway because
in the end most people are going to use
compile definition
yes or whatever whatever
function there is like that yeah this
will be very nice for 13.1 this this
will be a good feature
okay so we settled on this fib fib yeah
i think so
fine great
fantastic
all right
great i'm excited
okay what else
um
well yeah i mean there's there's some
down code stuff
and then there's some packed with stuff
those i think are both
those are coming stuff is definitely a
rabbit hole yeah um
but let me just get a sense of this i
mean so okay i mean
basically the idea is that
uh you you know basically you just
you're going to be giving it function
names and then those functions get
compiled and the result is put in the
down code um and and basically this
argument structure
is going to be
is going to be unified with the argument
structure of function compile um for
like the main function function compile
um so basically it's the same as
normally you write function compile and
then you give it you know
a list of functions to compile and give
you compiled code functions this would
do the same thing but it will put the
results in down code
okay
um
rewind back to the one of the nice
things about the down values thing is
you can give polymorphic types you can
give like a for all type
this thing here is always going to be
concrete types so there's there's no
type for all in this what's the
relationship between this and the
compiled definition
idea well the compile definition is just
both of these things together it's just
the compiled down value plus the down
code composition stuff right and in fact
it's it's even a pretty simple usage of
both of them together yeah um
but
but actually i mean tom that the thing
about the thing i don't think these have
to be fundamentally concrete they
definitely will be at least initially
but i mean the in the same way you can
have these sort of rapper harness
functions for for down value compilation
you could have the same thing for for
down code compilation
but how do you know what type to
to make it for you know you get
an integer and a real how do you know
what no sure well i mean it's unreal you
can tell but but if it's a integer 64
integer 32
then you can't necessarily tell um so
yeah i think that's a solvable or you
yeah you get like f of one you know how
do you know what what type
because there might be many car and even
like instagram you know real an integer
could become the type could be a real it
could be an integer it could be you know
yeah yeah i i think i think it's a
solvable problem like i think i i agree
you know it's like technically a little
ambiguous but i think we can either pick
something or we can throw an error at
compile time that basically says please
specify my types unambiguously yeah yeah
yeah um but
yeah okay down values really can be
polymorphic they really really can be
polymorphic and actually
that's that's that's pretty useful when
we do that but anyway yes fine you mean
that you mean that the thing can take an
integer or a real and there are two
separate pieces of down code one for the
integer case one for the real case oh
i'm saying you have
you have the down code and it'll make a
a case for the real in a case for the
integer
if you use it right
right okay all right let's quick look at
the the paclit thing just for preview
okay just to be very quick very quick so
um basically
okay basically the idea is
in your packet you will write uh and
some of these names are also kind of uh
up for grabs but but you write something
like register compiled component you
know the name of your component or
packet or whatever and then there are
different things that you can sort of
register so here i might register
declarations and give it a bunch of
compiler declarations and that way when
i load my packlet or when i load this
compiled component all these
declarations will show up in my compiler
environment
i might also specify something like
exported functions and i give it a bunch
of function names which align with
functions that are declared in this
compiled component
and if i if i have these exported
functions then what what that means is
when the compiled component is built
because there'll be a function for build
compiled component it will compile these
functions
like it'll compile them and put them in
a dynamic library and then when i load
them they'll be loaded into down code so
basically this is a way of saying you
know i can declare some function here
and then i can just tell it by the way
please export this function and then
when i load the packet and the compiled
component i'll actually have this as a
as a callable down code compiled
function
um
that i can use elsewhere in the backlit
right so this is very cool i mean this
is basically taking
it's another
sort of system component that becomes
installable via paclets
correct correct yes this is the way it
works
rather not not completely finished
version but you can put metadata in the
info.m so the paclet system will find
all of these packlets without having to
load them i mean it's it's pretty cool
actually
so yeah
right since you can have like a compiled
component that's called a bit more
there's there's some nice you know
there's sharon yeah so there's some
stuff with um
right so then you you call you call
build and and it will it will take some
time and it'll pop you know it'll make a
folder in your packet that's you know
library resources or something and then
when you call load it will you know
load in all that stuff to find the down
code you know etc etc give you all this
extra information if you want
and and another thing you can do is you
can call you know
when you when you uh well when you
create a compiler environment um you can
specify what compiled components do you
want included in this environment it's
like calling needs or something and then
you can do something like this to the
idea
the thing that tom was just mentioning
was that the uh right that basically
this can work even if the packet isn't
loaded because it can look at the
packlet infos and in the packet info
it'll see my component is defined in
this pathway and then it will go and
fetch it and so on and it'll load it
automatically how does the packet
lymphos expose themselves
in other words is the innards of a
packet info exposed
because it's an api todd has quite quite
nice things for this
um i don't know if todd's here but no i
don't know do you want to see an example
do you no no because we need to probably
wrap this up but
um but i mean i'm just getting some
sense here so just the road map is
for 13 1
you're getting to the point where you
can compile down down
values
the installation of that as a down
code-like thing is one of the next
coming attractions correct correct yes
and then and then
yeah yeah well and then and then there's
there's sort of being able to
to do that in a packlin so that you can
you know release you can have a packet
that has down code compiled functions
right but i mean there's there's huge
rafts of like well from alpha code that
could potentially be once there is down
value compilation down
huge rafts of code that could be
attempted to be compiled
yes yes yes um i put a thing in the chat
window that
it's not formatted very nicely but you
can do this compiler extension thing
in the practice info and
that's
you know advertises it you see but yeah
yes absolutely to all of that stephen
correct yes totally
right okay so that i see so there's a
kernel
piece and there's a um
i mean this is just how packed infos
work so this is actually an old style
packet object it's not using the new
syntax but yeah yeah
right but but but um right so you can
you can there's this extensions area and
every packet object say what does this
packet provide and then
uh
right and so then you can tell it prices
component and i think there's discovery
stuff even for like the the kernel
context stuff so it knows if you call
needs on this context that okay this is
the packet associated with this context
and so on yes yes yes
so it's the same thing here it says this
is the packet associated with this
compiled component
the whole business about i've got some
random function it's got things in it
that do not have a direct compiler
hookup
first of all have the number of compiler
hookups dramatically increased
by compiler hook up streaming functions
that are that are kernel functions
callable from the compiler yes
not really i mean we we don't have like
a million graph functions and so on but
yeah
that's a shame is it is it ready to
increase is it just a question of
somebody doing it yes it will it will be
very ready because we'll have the
compiled expression declaration which is
one of the big things okay so then we're
we're launching an army to do that
yes i mean we can
okay
well that's a separate discussion but we
should make sure that we actually have
uh
you know recruits for that army
correct yeah i mean i have several
examples like good stuff you have some
examples there's there's absolutely
geometry and stuff yeah
it's not dates and times and things like
that that that we should it's really
important to get that done and then and
then and then for the callbacks when it
can't do that when one of those is
missing and has to execute a callback is
that nice and clean yet or not
what do you mean by executed callback i
mean the whole point is that all you
really need to do is you need to tell
the types if it doesn't know the types
it can't compile anything right because
it's just like you know it can't for
anything
so so it's
right
okay well
fine but the bigger honestly though the
bigger the the
right the the the main difficulty in
doing that is is just designing the
types for representing the ontology of
types correct absolutely right i mean
like for example with the graph stuff
you know
right like there are different ways of
doing it for example maybe you have one
graph type to match the fact that we
have one graph object but you probably
have a different directed edge versus
undirected edge type you know or maybe
you don't maybe you just have one edge
type and it has a boolean field that's
whether it's directed or not but if you
have two different types then what's the
type of edge list
right is it a a list of directed edges
or a list of undirected edges or is it a
list of
some union type of directory
this is where i parametrize it with the
metadata you store on nodes and edges i
i get it i get it i mean this is why
in a an unmanaged situation or whatever
you know like like we we noticed that
lean has 80 000 theorems and 30 000
definitions
right
that's that's a lot
well yes but i mean it probably means
that
that this whole process of you know this
concept of design
that
you know minimizes the number of
different structures and so on
you know is non-trivial to implement
that and i agree right right making the
type ontology
one one other point is just as a quick
point one other point is that i think
for several areas their types are much
simplified if we have sort of nice union
types and and type sums and things
which we don't really have right now and
that's a whole other
pretty sort of big project that i think
is going to be important but i mean
there's still lots of areas you can do
without those well so you're saying we
shouldn't do a bunch of areas which we
will actually want to typify with type
unions if we don't have type unions
yeah i mean i i'm saying things like
here here's an example right suppose
suppose we have a directed edge and
undirected edge type which is one
decision we might make
um
okay in that case we probably have a
directed a directed graph and an
undirected graph right you see if you
have a graph it's parameterized by its
directedness and we probably have a
third one that's called you know mixed
graph which is you know the mixed case i
mean this is internally how the kernel c
code works because it has several as
even as like even more different ways of
defining graphs in terms but but
whatever and so if we have if you call
edge list non-directed graph it knows
what's due undirected graph knows what
to do but for example if you call
edgelist on an undirected graph
you you actually kind of need type you
know union types there's there's really
nothing else you can do
um and so i think that the problem is
right now we have these very low level
union types that have we're not even
exposing the interface because it's too
kind of you know it's too kind of weird
and you have to call switch on them if
you ever want to use them and and so on
and and basically uh
right so i think it makes it makes
efficient safe code as well so that's
but yes yes
i mean there's improvements but you know
yes
right i mean i think the basic point
though is that is that
you know if if we for example had a
edgeless returning uh list vector of of
these you know of some union type of of
directly undirected edges it would not
really be very usable right now so i
think we don't want to implement that in
some way that's
correct it's going to be very bizarre i
think those things we haven't thought
through absolutely yes so right but
again usually these are like that's one
usage but there's still you know several
other usages of functions like edgeless
which are just fine
so yeah yeah
like dates
actually would be good okay so has
somebody done an inventory across the
system of what we can get to
typifying and compiling
next yeah i mean i i have a i have a big
list i don't think we should visit that
both types and i have a big list of sort
of subject areas that could be uh
that could be sort of
right compilerified
it's surprisingly long
i mean both the like for the types you
know i made a list of types that need to
have equivalents in the compiler which
will have equivalence through you know
compile expression declaration you know
things like date object and time series
and whatever and and you know in like 10
minutes i had over 100 of them
and and then you know for for subject
areas i mean i had like at least like 25
or 30 subject areas
so that are accessible today you're
saying no that that that are sort of
like
you know clear well-defined things like
graphs or geometry
you know or you know file i o
import export etc right they're not
accessible today because of the lack of
type union and so on but uh there are
presumably are some areas that are
accessible today even without type union
oh yeah i mean these are all just ones
that are generally
things that we eventually want
most of them i think are accessible
without type union there are little bits
of them that are not accessible without
type unions
but yeah
well it's very cool okay
so is there any more that we have to
look at for thirteen 13-1
no but do you want another like review
documentation session for 13.1 what i
wouldn't mind seeing it i i don't think
it needs to be a full
i i would expect you guys you guys are
experienced enough i'm not sure that i'm
really going to have that much to say
plus also there's not an area where i
you know
know i mean
unfortunately this documentation is not
going to have the feature that there is
an unbelievably simple basic example
that can be given
typically
because it's quite you know entangled
yep yeah
and most of them have have relatively
simple first examples but yeah
how many pages are we talking about i
mean is there a guide page
there's no well there's like
the guide page has to be updated i
haven't done it yet but i have like i
mean
they're all listed experimental but
they're like
i think like
20 or so new symbols
okay
with documentation so yeah
okay
great stuff
all right okay good stuff okay thanks
guys